A couple of weeks ago, I interviewed Viveca Novak from McClatchy about her team's investigation
into
funding from russia to trump
Specifically through the NRA the National Rifle Association, and this was the type of interview that it's very interesting
But it often doesn't do super well, like I don't think when the interview was over
That we thought this interview is gonna hit a nerve. It's gonna
do incredibly well and blow up but it actually did hit a nerve on a couple of fronts. one is that the YouTube clip for
that interview with Viveca Novak was
Immediately brigaded by the types of comments that often end up being the troll bots and the Russian bots online spreading disinformation
Anytime anything critical of Russia is mentioned, but secondly it also did quite well
It's got about a hundred thousand views so far and neither of those is that common for a 15-minute interview with a McClatchy
Reporter about something related to campaign finance and following the money trail and now the story is
blowing up even more this Russia NRA Trump funding story has sort of gone mainstream
And the NRA is acting really really shady about it Democratic Senator Ron Wyden
wrote two letters
Asking about some of these links between the NRA and Moscow and between the NRA and Russian Nationals
And the NRA is refusing to answer the questions that Senator Wyden has asked they sent out this really
aggressively worded but lacking almost any specific details letter
Basically just saying hey listen. We follow election law and we don't accept foreign funds period
And that it's really the Russian dude who allegedly gave them money That's being investigated
Not the NRA basically saying, "senator Wyden, leave us the hell alone." Now of course the letter from the NRA
Doesn't actually address the specific
allegations including that NRA officials went to Moscow in late 2015
It doesn't address the source of the thirty million dollars in funding that the NRA gave to Donald Trump
it doesn't address the broader funding of the NRA by Russia beyond
specifically for Donald Trump's campaign
and it also doesn't address the existence of
Shell companies that are reportedly being used for this funding in other words
This is getting way more interesting what started with us as a story that
while very relevant did not have sort of mainstream
penetration when I see this non denial
I become more convinced that Viveca Novak and McClatchy and her team
are onto something with their reporting and that yes the NRA is accepting money from Russia
and what people need to realize
Sort of at the highest level in the broadest scope is that the NRA is not a patriotic organization
even by Trump's use of this horrible slogan America first the NRA is not an America first organization
the NRA uses the idea of being patriotic
as marketing for themselves
To then actually work on their real loyalty which is to gun manufacturers, period.
it has nothing to do with
country for the NRA it has nothing to do with safety for the NRA it has nothing to do with anything other than
"Give us money, which we can use to get more guns sold for our clients, who are the gun manufacturers"
that's the reality
and it didn't used to be that way the NRA started as a gun safety organization
It was geared towards the individual members
And it was only a few decades ago that they started taking money from those gun manufacturers
having those corrupting influences remember that Wayne LaPierre
Video from 1999, you see that he advocated for gun-free zones in schools you never see that today
I actually read and I I don't have it in front of me
I'm going off memory, but there was a prior either director or higher up of the NRA
Who actually correct me if I'm wrong
But I believe he said something like I don't even own a gun myself like I don't even like the idea of
Carrying a firearm, but we're here to- we're going to defend the Second Amendment because it exists
I don't remember who that was I mean, it's almost kind of does seem logical. It's it's shocking that we are so shocked by that
So listen the NRA they'll go to Russia
They'll ignore. The shootings strategically they'll flaunt the American flag and a bald eagle or whatever other symbols
They'll use, but fundamentally this is a marketing and lobbying organization for gun manufacturers, period.
now you can say I like that I like organizations that ignore public health and
Country and everything else just to sell guns or you can be against that but you have to understand what it is, to
Honestly and sort of accurately analyze it and a lot of people don't. they see the NRA as
this patriotic organization what it really is is a truly horrible
Lobby for the gun manufacturers and in the meantime the distract-a-thon continues
it's not, "Is Obama using the wrong mustard," but it's
What's going on with Hillary's emails and what's going to be going on with this
investigation into Russia funding Bernie Sanders and meanwhile
This is a really big story that we've been covering that has been mostly ignored by corporate media
And my hope is that it now does go mainstream?
Russia's interest in doing this if you're wondering like why would Russia even want to fund the NRA
Russia's interest in doing this is to create chaos the NRA is interest is having more money with which they can promote gun sales and
Missing from both of their goals is anything that would be good for the actual people of the United States
Do not misunderstand for a second what the goals are of each player in this entire
Fiasco the video you just finished watching was made possible by you through the membership program
You can sign up for membership at DavidPakman.com/Membership
We are viewer supported independent media. You can use the coupon code
"IVOTED17" for a 40% discount off of your membership